thousands of people continue to march on
the streets of cheating the frustrations
of demonstrators are rooted in social
inequalities many believe are getting
worse one of the most iconic
manifestations of this discontent is an
indigenous banner belonging to Chile's
Mapuche le salon gone is a mutt witch's
scholar and one of the original
designers of the flag
she says the history of this
marginalized group is what's made the
flag and emblem of resistance among
Sheila's demonstrators we should
recognize that this struggle is about
diverse sectors that have been excluded
women young people sexual diversity
migrants who are all part of a reality
in Chile that has been denied the flag
has begun to appear more and more in
street protests and it served to
highlight one of the many inequalities
Chileans point to that the country's
constitution doesn't guarantee the
rights of indigenous people the Mapuche
have always been oppressed and today I
identify more with indigenous flag than
with the Chilean flag many other flags
are also visible at demonstrations
representing just about every sector of
society it's the diversity of Chilean
protesters and their wide range of
demands that together have sparked the
largest social mobilization in a
generation I see - like wow this is
Chile's national flag with holes burned
through it Jose Ignacio says it
symbolizes the more than 23 people who
have lost their lives in the violence I
mean melody I won't talk it would hurt
me to see a new constitution written
that doesn't consider them a pure cause
or the cause of sexual diversity I'd be
upset if everything we've worked for and
fought for ended in a constitution that
doesn't take into account all of the
voices more than 2,000 people have been
injured in protests since the crisis
began four weeks ago the calls for
justice over the deaths of demonstrators
ensures the unrest will continue Manuel
de pollo al Jazeera Santiago Chile